So should I just do it now?
Yup.
President Obama: That's how we forged a Trans-Pacific
Partnership, to open markets and protect workers
and the environment, and advance American
leadership in Asia.
It cuts 18,000 taxes on products made in America,
which will then support more good jobs here
in America.
With TPP, China does not set the rules in
that region, we do.
Derek: President Obama mentioned the Trans-Pacific
Partnership in his speech tonight, but he
should have said a lot more.
One reason that he didn't say more may be
that he's in favor, but Democratic presidential
candidate Hillary Clinton is opposed.
On the Republican side, Ted Cruz is opposed,
Jeb Bush is in favor.
The reason for all this disagreement is that
Trans-Pacific Partnership is a really big
deal.
It's 6,000 pages long.
It's going to affect America in a lot of ways,
now and in the future.
One positive thing the President mentioned,
it's going to cut taxes on 18,000 goods and
services that are coming into the United States,
making them cheaper for ordinary Americans.
But the President also said it allows us to
make the rules instead of China, and that's
not really true.
The rules on intellectual property, on state
owned enterprises, on services exports in
which American firms are the best in the world,
they're all too weak.
We need to change them.
President Obama talked about looking toward
the future, and in the future the TPP is only
going to get more important to the U.S., but
if it were to help the U.S., we need to make
it better.
And if we can't make it better under President
Obama, then we're going to need to make it
better under the next President.
So what are your thoughts on President Obama's
legacy?
Let us know in the comments, and check out
these other videos by AEI scholars.